[Música]
fin de una era a los 96 años murió la
Reina Isabel II y quien ocupó el trono
británico durante 70 años según el
anuncio de la familia real la monarca
falleció de manera pacífica en el
castillo de balmoral en Escocia solo
unas horas después de que expresaran
máxima preocupación por su salud
Carlos III del Reino Unido es el nombre
oficial escogido por el hijo mayor de la
fallecida Reina Isabel II que se
convierte ahora en el nuevo rey de
Inglaterra y ASUME el trono a Los 73
años de edad
el mundo lamenta la muerte de la reina
Isabel segunda jefes de estado y de
gobierno de varios países enviaron sus
mensajes de condolencia a la familia
real recordaron el legado de la monarca
y recalcaron la tenacidad que tuvo
durante su reinado
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz el mundo despidió este 8 de
septiembre de 2022 a uno de los
personajes más significativos de la
historia moderna a los 96 años falleció
la Reina Isabel II y con su partida se
marca el fin de toda una era muy bien el
castillo de balmoral en Escocia de
manera tranquila según anunció la
familia real los médicos habían
expresado horas antes su preocupación
por el estado de salud de la monarca que
ya había presentado quebrantos a lo
largo de los últimos meses veamos un
resumen de lo ocurrido hoy en Reino
Unido un país que está de luto
[Música]
es un momento histórico y el fin de una
era la monarca más longeva de Reino
Unido la Reina Isabel II ha muerto a los
96 años después de reinar durante 70
años pocos días después de que la reina
la nombrara como primera ministra Lis
tras expresó sus condolencias
todos estamos desolados por la noticia
que acabamos de escuchar desde balmoral
la muerte de Su Majestad la reina Es una
gran conmoción para la nación y para el
mundo la Reina Isabel II fue la roca
sobre la que se construyó Reino Unido
el hijo mayor de Isabel II Carlos
encabezará un luto del país como nuevo
rey en un comunicado el Rey Carlos III
dijo que todo el mundo extrañará a su
madre
el fallecimiento de mi querida madre Su
Majestad la reina Es un momento de
máxima tristeza para mí y para todos los
miembros de mi familia sé que su pérdida
se sentirá profundamente en todo el país
los reinos Y la commonwealth y por
innumerables personas en todo el mundo
las banderas de todo Reino Unido ondean
a media hasta y el país ha entrado en un
periodo de luto nacional que durará 10
días la familia de la reina se trasladó
a Escocia para estar a su lado a primera
hora del jueves después de las
advertencias de los doctores que desde
temprano se dijeron preocupados por su
estado de salud desde finales del año
pasado sufría constantes problemas de
movilidad que lo obligaron a cancelar
casi todos sus compromisos públicos la
Reina Isabel II llegó al Trono en 1952
cuando apenas tenía 25 años y es que la
Reina Isabel II deja detrás todo un
legado con sólo 25 años asumió el trono
y vio la transición de su reino que como
un imperio se transformó en el
commonwealth a lo largo del siglo XX
atravesó diversos cambios sociales y
momentos clave en la historia de la
humanidad como la guerra fría la caída
del muro de Berlín El colapso de la
unión soviética y el brexit y fue una de
las personalidades más admiradas del
mundo hagamos un repaso a los instantes
más importantes de su vida
para la celebración de sus 90 años
Isabel segunda vistió como de costumbre
un traje y un sombrero del mismo color
una imagen que se hizo icónica en su
destino no estaba al convertirse en
soberana pero en 1936 cuando su tío
Eduardo octavo renunció al Trono por
amor fue su padre Jorge vi quien se
convirtió en rey
la muerte súbita de su padre en 1952 la
puso en el trono tenía solo 25 años de
edad y su coronación fue vista en
televisión por más de 20 millones de
personas en todo el mundo
[Música]
tras su entronización vinieron tiempos
turbulentos la decadencia del imperio
británico poco a poco las antiguas
colonias británicas fueron reclamando su
independencia nace entonces la
mancomunidad de Naciones en el Reino
Unido se vive el swing mondon de los 60s
y la existencia de la monarquía
británica en pleno Siglo XX fue puesta
en entredicho
después de los cuentos de hadas los tres
hijos de la Reina Isabel se divorcian
uno después del otro en medio de varios
escándalos el clan real tambalea en 1997
la tragedia sacudió a la corona la
muerte de la princesa Diana sumergió el
reino en un profundo Duelo mientras la
reina se escudó tras su silencio una
reacción que afectó fuertemente a los
británicos Isabel II tardó una semana en
ordenar que las banderas fueran puestas
a media hasta
quiero rendirle personalmente un
homenaje a Diana ella fue un ser humano
de excepcional talento tanto en los
buenos como en los malos tiempos nunca
perdió su capacidad de sonreír y de
inspirar a otros con su calidez y bondad
con el tiempo Isabel volvió a ser
popular miles llenaron las calles para
celebrar sus jubileos en 2002 y 2012 las
bodas de Los Príncipes Guillermo con
Kate middleton y de Enrique con Meghan
markle así como el nacimiento de los
bisnietos trajeron colorido a una
monarquía envejecida pero también la
garantía de perpetuar la tradición a
través de las futuras generaciones contó
con la empatía del público cuando perdió
a su esposo el príncipe Felipe en 2021
en febrero de 2022 su salud causó
preocupación Cuando dio positivo por
Kobe 19 pero los superó e incluso dio un
discurso para dar ánimos y Esperanza a
la población contra la enfermedad en
junio de 2022 llegó una fecha clave el
jubileo de platino la monarca más
longeva de la historia del país
conmemoró sus 70 años de reinado en unas
festividades que duraron cuatro días con
la familia real reunida y miles de
personas siguiendo las celebraciones
Aunque Isabel se ausentó de varios
eventos por motivos de salud
Isabel fue para muchos una fuerza que
dio estabilidad al Reino Unido tanto en
los malos como en los buenos tiempos
y después de 70 años de ser El Heredero
el príncipe Carlos subirá al Trono de la
monarquía británica a Los 73 años tras
la muerte de la reina Isabel II a los 96
A diferencia de su madre el príncipe de
gales ha pasado la mayor parte de su
vida preparándose para el día en que se
convertirá en Rey Carlos III es el
nombre que escogió para su reinado ha
sido El Heredero al Trono durante la
mayor parte de su vida El príncipe
Carlos se convirtió el primero en la
línea de sucesión con solo tres años fue
el comienzo de una vida de preparación
para su papel como futuro Rey basada en
gran parte a la sombra de su madre tras
una educación privada Carlos se
convirtió en el primer heredero al Trono
en obtener una licenciatura tras
graduarse en Cambridge en 1970 a los 20
años Fue investido como el vigésimo
primer príncipe de gales el título que
se otorga a Los Herederos masculinos del
Trono británico
yo Carlos príncipe de gales Me convierto
en su señor de la vida y de la fe
Carlos sirvió entonces en la real fuerza
aérea y en la Marina real
en 1981 se anunció el compromiso del
príncipe de gales y Lady Diana Spencer
de 19 años lo que llevó a la pareja a un
Frenesí mediático simplemente encantado
y feliz estoy asombrado de que haya sido
tan valiente como para aceptarme
Y supongo que enamorada claro
lo que sea que signifique estar
enamorado
unos meses después su boda fue vista por
750 millones de espectadores en todo el
mundo marcando un punto álgido de
popularidad para la familia real Los
Príncipes de gales tuvieron dos hijos el
príncipe Guillermo segundo en la línea
de sucesión al Trono y el príncipe Harry
su matrimonio se volvió cada vez más
tenso en medio de años de intensos
escrutinio y de rumores de infidelidad
por ambas partes que salpicaron las
portadas
del Palacio de buckingham que compensar
el príncipe y la princesa de gales han
decidido separarse en 1993 el romance de
Carlos con su antigua amiga y ex novia
Camila Parker Bones se hizo público
cuando se filtró la transcripción de una
llamada telefónica íntima en 1989 entre
ambos el príncipe admitió un adulterio
en un documental en 1997 un año después
de finalizar su divorcio Diana una
figura muy querida por el público
británico y más allá murió en un
accidente de coche en París
al principio Carlos y la reina parecían
no estar a la altura del dolor nacional
la popularidad de la familia real cayó
en picado
dos años más tarde Carlos y Camila
hicieron su primera aparición como
pareja la opinión pública de la pareja
era mixta se casaron en 2005 Desatando
años de cero debate sobre si Camila
sería algún día reina especulaciones que
solo terminaron cuando la Reina Isabel
manifestó su deseo de que Camila fuera
reina consorte Cuando Carlos se
convirtiera en Rey implicado en más de
400 organizaciones benéficas El príncipe
de gales es conocido por su labor
filantrópica que en ocasiones ha estado
en el punto de mira por sus polémicas
donaciones nos hemos reunido como padre
e hijo para prestar nuestra voz al
creciente esfuerzo mundial en la lucha
contra el comercio ilegal de especies
silvestres
también es uno de los miembros más
Francos de la familia real y con
frecuencia expresa su opinión en ámbitos
como la arquitectura el cambio climático
y el medio ambiente con el paso de los
años Fue asumiendo más funciones a
medida que la casa real se preparaba
para la transición y la salud de la
reina empeoraba la más notable fue leer
el discurso de la reina en su nombre
para abrir el parlamento por primera vez
en 2022 el año que celebró su 70 años en
el trono
señores y miembros de la cámara de los
comunes
la prioridad de gobierno para Su
Majestad es hacer crecer y fortalecer la
economía para la mayoría del público
británico la Reina Isabel es la única
monarca que han conocido y ha seguido
siendo muy popular a lo largo de sus
décadas en el trono el reinado de Carlos
marcará el comienzo de una era para una
familia real cuya reputación se ha visto
mermada por los escándalos mientras que
las encuestas han indicado una creciente
desafección con la monarquía entre los
jóvenes
Y es que la muerte de la reina Isabel II
ha traído la atención mundial jefes de
estado y de gobierno de varios países
reaccionaron al fallecimiento de la
monarca desde Rusia pasando por África y
los países miembros de la mancomunidad
de Naciones hasta América Latina se
pronunciaron Juan Pablo lucumi tiene los
detalles el Duelo se esparció por todo
el mundo y las repercusiones no se
detienen jefes de estado presidentes y
primeros ministros expresaron su sentido
pésame a la familia real por la muerte
de la reina Isabel segunda los
presidentes de Francia y Ucrania fueron
unos de los primeros en reaccionar Su
Majestad la Reina Isabel II encarnó la
continuidad y la unidad de la nación
británica durante más de 70 años guardó
el recuerdo de una amiga de Francia una
reina de corazones que marcó para
siempre su país y su siglo
con profunda tristementerado de la
muerte de Su Majestad la Reina Isabel II
una gran pérdida para toda Europa y el
mundo por parte de todos los ucranianos
expresó misma sinceras condolencias a la
familia real a todos Reino Unido y a
toda la mancomunidad de Naciones
pensamientos y oraciones están con
ustedes
los primeros ministros de los países
miembros de la mancomunidad de Naciones
Canadá Nueva Zelanda Australia e India
también rindieron homenaje de forma
pública Su Majestad la Reina Isabel II
será recordada como una incondicional de
nuestro tiempo ella brindó un liderazgo
inspirador a su nación y a su pueblo
ella personificó la dignidad y la
decencia en la vida pública dorido por
su fallecimiento mis pensamientos están
con su familia y la gente del Reino
Unido en esta triste hora la vecina
Irlanda con quien se mantiene una
turbulenta relación desde hace siglos
dio su sentido pésame a su familia de
pueblo en Duelo el gobierno Irlandés se
une a ustedes en el Duelo por la pérdida
de una mujer excepcional que lideró con
un ejemplo tranquilo y Digno y que tocó
tantas vidas durante su reinado
excepcionalmente largo en el continente
americano Estados Unidos México Perú
Brasil y Venezuela también se unieron
envió mis condolencias a los pueblos del
Reino Unido por el fallecimiento de la
Reina Isabel II monarca británica y
soberana de 14 estados independientes de
igual las hago extensivas a sus
familiares amigos y miembros de la casa
real fue la primera monarca británica
con la que personas de todo el mundo
pudieron sentir una conexión personal e
inmediata ya sea que la escucharon en la
radio como una joven princesa hablando
con los niños del Reino Unido o reunidas
alrededor de sus televisores para la
coronación mirando su último discurso de
Navidad o su jubileo de platino en sus
teléfonos y ella a su vez dedicó toda su
vida al servicio de ellos la ONU líderes
de la Unión Europea y de varias naciones
de África es colonias británicas y el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin
también guardaron luto a la reina más
longeva que ha tenido Reino Unido
y el presidente de Brasil y ayer
bolsonaro decretó tres días de luto los
detalles con nuestra corresponsal
Valeria sacconi
segunda se conoce en Brasil en plena
campaña electoral y un día después de la
celebraciones del Bicentenario de la
independencia de este país de hecho ayer
antes de morir la Reina Isabel felicitó
al gobierno brasileño por esa fecha y el
gobierno brasileño acaba de decretar
tres días de luto oficial para recordar
la importancia histórica de la reina que
dice todo solo una vez en su vida Brasil
fue En 1968 en aquella ocasión se reunió
incluso con el rey del fútbol con Pelé y
hoy los periódicos de Brasil ha
recordado ese encuentro mostrando esa
foto histórica otros políticos Además
del propio presidente Yair bolsonaro han
recordado la importancia de la reina
para la historia contemporánea incluido
el ex presidente Luis Ignacio Luna
hasta aquí este Informativo en francés
24 Gracias por acompañarnos los
invitamos a que continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]